yeah well so as of today chat GPT can
sort of get computational superpowers by
calling on both from Alpha and wolfen
language uh through its plug-in
mechanism and the you know chat GPT is a
large language model which has kind of
gone through the web and lots of books
and so on and it is piecing together
things by sort of seeing what a
reasonable piece of continuing text
would be and it's amazing how far that
gets and we'll we'll perhaps talk a
little bit later about why I think it
gets as far as it does but the thing it
isn't able to do is actually do sort of
serious computation it is just saying
let me continue this text based on
things that I've seen on the web and and
things that sort of seem reasonable
based on the structure of language as
humans have written it but when it comes
to actually Computing things that's just
not something a neural net like it does
but we've been building for a long time
now uh well Wolfram language